there are some critics Harold Bloom
among them who think that the Merchant
of Venice simply should never be
performed because it's to impossible to
present
Shylock in a way that won't foster
anti-semitism I think what makes any
great work of art great is a combination
of elements not all of which are
necessarily going to be savory so if you
cut Jim out of Huckleberry Finn or
certain unsavory references to him out
of Huckleberry Finn
you're diluting the work you're playing
with it's essential structure with the
fabric that makes it what it is people
have to read in context every era has
its own mores being too literal and
political correctness can be can be a
straightjacket I mean do we not listen
to Elisabeth Schwarzkopf the soprano
because she was possibly a collaborator
do we not watch our leti in movies or
maurice chevalier where do you draw that
line it's it's endlessly debatable but
you can't shut out everything that's
polluted in in art or else you wouldn't
have any art